[Music]
most people
listening to this show know what their
passion is and
and they may it could be a hobby it
could be you know they could love
reading they could love
playing tennis they could you know
they'll have passions and if you have a
passion
it makes sense to spend a lot of your
life in involved in that passion
and quite often you can turn your
passion uh
into a business you can see maybe
there's some
aspect of your passion that people are
not doing that well
and you know you can say screw it i
could do it
better um and i think all you know if
you spend your life
with your eyes open looking for um
looking for
things that frustrate you looking for a
gap gaps in the market
um that's all the business is it it's
fulfilling that you know filling in a
gap and
doing it better than it's been done by
anybody else and you know if people who
don't have closed minds will most likely
find those opportunities now i suspect
there will be
100 people who will have come up with
that idea before you
but those hundred people won't have had
the courage just to
go and do something about it so those
few people just say right i'm going to
give it a go
often end up you know being being
successful
and i think if you you know if you
believe in what you're doing
many people will tell you why you're
mistaken why it'll never work
but if you really believe passion in
what you're doing just just
keep going you know keep pushing on keep
pushing on until you either succeed or
at least you realize that it's just not
going to happen
and then if it if you don't succeed pick
yourself up and you know try again
and ultimately you know if you you're
that determined you will succeed in life
and if you don't you'll have a lot of
fun trying
i look at everything as an opportunity
you know i'm positive about
life generally and i generally feel that
you can find ways of solving problems
and making
things work and you know i'm definitely
a sort of glass
nearly full kind of person rather than a
glass half full so
i think out of being just a generally
positive person
you can make positive things happen
the absolute key is how good you are
with people
and if you genuinely care about people
if you can
surround yourself with people that
genuinely excited about what you're
doing
you know if you can draw out the best in
people if you're good at lavishing
praise on people and
not criticizing your people and and
inspiring your people
um you know that's that's something you
just have to do from day one
never use the i word i mean it's you're
a team we're doing this we're doing that
never ever you know let it sort of sense
center on yourself
and just be a great great leader of
people and you know if you can do that
from
from day one even if you've got one
other person working with you or two
other
people working with you then you know
you can enjoy the good times together
um but there will be bad times and those
that your people will
pull around for you they'll work day and
night to try to
you know keep whatever it is you're
creating alive
and make sure that survives so the
number one lesson is be a great people
person
uh to become an entrepreneur is not easy
and a lot of people who try to become
entrepreneurs they fail
along the way but good ones pick
themselves up and they try again they
try again until they succeed
and you know what what an entrepreneur
needs to do first of all is come up with
an idea that will make a positive
difference in other people's lives
and if you've got if you've got an idea
that's going to make a positive
difference to other people's lives
you've got a chance
of building a business play hard work
hard and then you know follow certain
principles in life you know
love people make make sure you make a
positive difference in this world
while you're on it
you